GOOD MORNING THE RULES
COMMITTEE FOR THURSDAY MARCH
THIRTY FIRST TWENTY TWENTY TWO
IS HEREBY CALLED ORDER PLEASE
ADVISE ON AUDIO AND VIDEO
RECORDING IS BEING MADE TO THESE
PROCEEDINGS IS ALSO BEING
TELEVISED MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC
ATTENDED THIS HEARING OR
ENCOURAGE WERE MASK AT ALL TIMES
ATTENDEES MUST ALSO REFRAIN FROM
CONDUCT THAT DISRUPTS DISTURBS
OR OTHERWISE IMPEDE TO ORDER A
COPY OF THIS HEARING. VIOLATIONS
OF THESE RULES MAY SUBJECT AN
INDIVIDUAL TO REMOVAL OR OTHER
ENFORCEMENT PROCESS AND I WANT
TO LET THE RECORD REFLECT THAT
MR LEVINE IS RE JOINING US TODAY
ASSISTANCE AND CONDUCT OF OUR
BUSINESS THANK YOU SLIMMER
LEVINE ON THE SECTOR PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL COOLEY HERE WALDRON
BENNETT FLORA FONG. GIPSON HERE
LEE HERE MAIENSCHEIN. MATHIS
RUBIO. LEVINE MCCARTY L. STATE
FOR THE RECORD MISTER MAN IS
HERE IN THE ABSENCE OF
ESTHERVILLE APPROVAL HE'S
APPOINTED FOR THE DAY- WE HAVE A
CONSENT AGENDA- MATTER VICE
CHAIR. I WOULD RESPECTFULLY
REQUEST WE REMOVE ITEM NINE THE
URGENCY REQUEST FROM THE CONSENT
AND VOTE ON IT SEPARATELY FOR
GOOD THAT SHALL BE THE ORDER- SO
ITEM NINE WILL BE REMOVED FROM
THE CONSENT AGENDA FOR SEPARATE
VOTE IS OUR MOTION AMANDA
CONSENT AGENDA- RUSSIA MATHIS
SECONDED BY- OKAY- MICEX SERVICE
CALL THE ROLL COOLEY HI COOLEY
AYE WALDRON WALDRON AYE BENNETT
FORA FONG FONG AYE GIPSON
GIPSON. WE AYE MAIENSCHEIN
MAIENSCHEIN AYE MATHIS MATHIS
AYE RUBIO RUBIO AYE LEVINE HI
LEVINE HI MUCH INTERESTED TO
MOTIONS PASSED- AND OF. THAT
DOES THAT IT TAKES CARE OF OUR
BUSINESS TODAY THIS WILL SCREEN.
WE NEED- ALL I'M SORRY. I GOT
LOST OKAY THANK YOU- IS OUR MOST
RIDER NINE. MOVERSE GIVE SECOND
BY BLANCA RUBIO I'M A SUCKER
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL COOLEY AYE
COOLEY AYE WALDRON WALDRON NOW
BENNETT FLORA FONG. FONG HI
GIPSON GIPSON HI LI LI HI
MAIENSCHEIN MAIENSCHEIN AYE
MATHIS. MATHIS NO RUBIO RUBIO HI
LEVINE LEVINE HI- SENATE I ON
THE URGENCY BECAUSE REQUEST FOR
AB TWENTY SIX OH EIGHT- AND ON
THE AND- HAS ENCOUNTERED MR VENT
. BENNETT ARE CONSENT BENNETT HI
. OKAY OF THAT. THE RESULT I
MEAN FOR THE COMMITTEE DISK
RULES WHO IS A GERMAN.